do appear to have lost the spanish
foreign minister we'll try and see if we
can uh uh
get back get her back on the line in
just a moment or two
but from what the minister was
suggesting there uh a
degree of disbelief that an agreement
can't be made on fishing uh
it does rather sound like perhaps uh
there was a
closeted criticism uh of the eu
negotiator's site
uh we will see if we can uh we will see
if we can get that late can we get back
to the minister
no we can't i'm afraid we'll see if we
can get that later on in the show so
let's move on slightly
uh if it feels it certainly does for me
uh like these brexit arguments have been
going on
for years that is because they have uh
almost four years ago
the uk's ambassador to the eu surviving
rogers resigned
blasting ill-founded arguments and
muddled thinking about brexit
in his resignation letter to colleagues
surviving of course what's in brussels
for many years pleased to say he joins
us on the programme now it's an evan
very good morning to you
um i wonder if i'll start with you in
the same way that i'm doing
with every one of our guests this
morning from your position how likely is
it that we're going to get a deal by the
end of today
i wouldn't have thought it was very
likely by the end of today but that's a
very different question from whether we
get it by the end of the year i think
so i i think it's odds against today but
i'm not sure i'm not sure the talks will
break down today either
most of these deadlines in in brexit
over the many over many years have
carried on being broken and i suspect
this might be the latest but we'll see
yeah if i had a pound for every time
i've said on there it's a crunch week in
terms of brexit i would have
quite a lot of pounds um but let's focus
then
on the state of the negotiations uh as
they stand
speaking to the spanish foreign minister
there the two key sticking points from
the european union side
fishing and level playing field i mean
on both of those
do you see them as a substantive at
points of divergence from the european
union's position
or are they playing a little bit of
politics here oh no i think this is real
and substantive
uh i think level playing field has
always been the issue and this goes
right back incidentally to 2016
uh when i was thinking about this before
the referendum let alone immediately
afterwards
this was obviously going to be the
sticking point and the potential
breaking point and i have been one of
those saying for many years that
it was highly likely that we would end
up with no deal so this doesn't surprise
me at all that the crunch comes over
level playing field
on fisheries look it's enormously
complex uh
extremely political on both sides going
right up to leaders level even though
the economic stakes as the spanish
foreign minister has just been telling
you are
may not be enormous that doesn't that
doesn't matter when it comes to
leaders perceptions both our own leaders
and key leaders across the european
union
i've always thought it was in principle
soluble because it's in both sides
interest to do a deal on fisheries they
need
stable and continuous and reliable
access to our territorial waters
we need access to be able to sell our
processed fish into the european market
without
um duties and quotas so there's a deal
to be done there but it's mightily
difficult to do it it will require
transition periods it will require a bit
of fudge about exactly what happens at
the end
but i've never thought it would break
down on fisheries i do think it could
break down over level playing field
because that goes to the heart of what
brexit is for
in the eyes of those who promoted brexit
the complaints are ivan from from the
british side as it co as regards level
playing field
it's not necessarily that you know there
wouldn't be they wouldn't be allowed to
diverge in future
more that the european union would be
able to unilaterally
impose uh your tariffs of of some form
i mean isn't there a way out of this in
some independent arbitration process
some joint arbitration process uh uk eu
i mean
those options whilst they're discussed
in the papers don't seem to be getting
much traction in brussels
well by definition we don't know exactly
what will get traction in the
in the talks in brussels and i'd be
surprised if they weren't all manner of
propositions on the table why else are
they carrying on talking
um the problem here is there's a
philosophical divide and an ideological
divide and it's not just
practical arrangements could could
technocrats on both sides devise a set
of arrangements with which they might
well be happy
and believe that they could manage this
process because what we're talking about
here why is this so difficult and i said
all along it was so difficult rather
than the easiest trade deal in history
one of the most difficult because we're
diverging um and trade deals are mostly
between
nearly always between partners who are
seeking to get closer together and
remove
and reduce and eliminate trade barriers
between jurisdictions
in this case we're obviously raising
trade barriers between jurisdictions
because we're seeking to get further
away that must be the purpose of brexit
why are you doing brexit unless you want
to diverge in material respects from
the law book that you're leaving when
you leave the european union
but the management of that process is
inevitably difficult obviously from the
uk
angle uh ministers will think well we're
free and we're sovereign
and we're autonomous and we can go our
own way and they want that to be a world
without consequences on the european
market
the european side is inevitably saying
well hang on we're not going to give you
any assurances that there won't be
consequences on the european market it
depends
what you do with your divergence uh how
far you diverge and how deliberately you
try and undercut our market as they see
it so
this was always going to be extremely
sort of toxic and difficult debate
to get through could you find technical
solutions and arbitration processes and
dispute resolution mechanisms that work
in my view yes you could but the
question for all of us is
if you could why have they not already
done so if this was simply a technical
and administrative question they would
have solved it by now
and it isn't just that it's a
philosophical question about
where are we going and to what extent
are there any constraints on our room
for maneuver after we've gone
given all of that given your description
of the difficulties and and the toxicity
in fact of these negotiations at
a point boris johnson of course went to
brussels this week for that dinner with
ursula wonderland i'm wondering should
the prime minister have inserted himself
in this process
a little bit sooner than than this last
week
given the fact that from what you're
saying it's it's it's an injection of
political will that appears to be
required most of all
well it's it's obviously been an
extraordinarily difficult few months so
it's very difficult to comment from the
outside when you're outside the system
and we've had copied 19 which is an
enormous
economic and public health crisis
running at the same time and it's not
impossible to hop on a plane
uh and get over so there are lots of
sort of uh mitigating circumstances here
um yes i do think this required an
injection of political will and
political momentum
earlier on if we were not to reach the
crunch point i've always thought that
christmas 2020 would be the biggest
crisis of brexit and here we are
so it's not a great surprise but it does
require political will
political guidance the negotiators can
sit in a room for weeks on end and
pretty much have in the last few weeks
but unless they've got
new elements to their mandate the
european union won't change its mandate
i imagine the prime minister isn't
changing david frost's mandate but you
have to know what room for maneuver you
have within that mandate to explore
options at this stage otherwise they're
just going to go around in ever
decreasing circles
how does the european union view our
prime minister boris johnson how is he
characterized
by those in positions of power there
well i think it's very difficult to
generalize i mean people deal with who
they deal with they know that he was
a key player if not the key player in in
getting brexit through
uh they know that brought down um not
only uh
david cameron after the referendum but
uh
theresa may in 2019 because her version
of brexit was unsaleable to the party
and unstable to the people led by boris
johnson
so they are well aware of the history
sometimes i think the uk side can be a
little bit naive in not understanding
that for many of the europeans involved
in this process
they've been through this many times
before with many different uk prime
ministers
and they tend to have more longevity and
experience on dealing with this
than many on the uk side who may be
going through this for the for the first
time
i think this week to be very candid i
think they felt that there was some
degree of naivety if not worse on the
british side to believe that
somehow if you could just get to leaders
and to
fraumerical and muslim and they could
break through
in some way they'd be in a different
position for michelle barnier and they
would sort it out at leader level
that's simply not when you're a third
country and you're outside the european
union that's not the way the european
union is
ever going to negotiate with the third
country leader whether it's boris
johnson or anybody else
so this sense that the uk sometimes has
that it's being uniquely victimized
you know i've sat dealing with third
countries and
non-european players in the european
union for uh
representing the uk for a very long time
this is how the eu
deals on trade issues with any third
country partner
and you don't get to see individual
leaders to try and divide and rule the
european union that's never going to
work
so i think wednesday didn't go very well
it doesn't surprise me it didn't go very
well all the signs were bad before the
dinner
and there were very clear messages in
what fran merkel said to the bundestag
on wednesday morning
that there were going to be difficulties
over non-regression and evolution
clauses and
indeed there are so ivan rogers
lovely to see you this morning and very
merry christmas to you and yours when it
comes
thank you very much